foreign
[Music]
I have neighbors so this is really
embarrassing
[Music]
Hammer ons pull-offs slides harmonics
all kinds of things I've just never
heard of before it's kicking my ass in a
good way
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are on the road was that the plan no
you're supposed to be working right now
welcome do you want a map oh yes things
I love national parks so much should I
stay here
it's tangenting decisions decisions so
pretty wow I just stopped by
The Watchman Campground out of curiosity
to see if there was anything open and
there's a ton of space
and it's only twenty dollars a night so
the sun's gonna set in like four hours
and then tomorrow it's supposed to snow
the filmmaker and me wants to stay do I
have chocolate my teeth probably anyway
the filmmaker in me wants to stay
and go explore the park during the snow
because it's going to be beautiful
however
the van lifer in me is not sure it's a
good idea because I won't have any power
because I won't be driving to Vegas to
like juice up my battery
and um
so I don't really know what I would do
tonight like it's just going to be
another lost day of productivity
essentially
um and I I'm not sure how the van will
handle in the snow
what do I do
is what I should be doing is getting my
butt someplace where I can have lots of
power
for my laptop so I can work I'm leaning
towards staying you guys let's check the
battery we'll see what it's at
oh 75 that's pretty good
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so I stayed outside of Vegas for
three weeks which was amazing I've never
really explored that area but it was so
cool for camping anyway I kind of went
down a rabbit hole about Vegas on
YouTube and there's a whole underground
city that lives in the sewer tunnels
beneath Las Vegas I thought that was so
fascinating this documentary filmmaker
went underground to film and interviewed
these people who had built entire like
there was a bed and a generator and had
hanging lights and makeshift closet and
they
go out into the town to get water and
refuel and supplies and then come back
to their home
in these sewer tunnels I just thought
that was so fascinating it's amazing how
there are just worlds within worlds and
so many of them
we have no idea even exists
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
the following is intended only for
mature audiences viewer discretion
advised
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the part where I remember why I
live on the road because I freaking love
it because I get to see
beautiful places like this
during times of the year when no one's
out here the last time I was in Zion it
was stop and go stop and go hardly
anywhere to pull over and really enjoy
the place and
there's just no one here I mean that's
not true there are people but very
little and the weather's perfect
the sun decided to come out so we're
getting sun and clouds like sunset's
going to be amazing I'm calling it right
now it's going to be epic I don't know I
just feel like it's worth saying
even though there are a lot of
challenges with living on the road and I
do think that it holds me back in some
ways
um professionally
it's just it's hard to describe the way
it feels
constantly being in the presence of
places like this I mean it's just so
beautiful and the energy and the smell
because it rained last night everything
just smells so fresh and so wild and
it's just
it makes my heart Happy
and I do question
when I have a house
will I still come out to these places as
often
I mean I literally come to these places
not just because I love them and they're
beautiful but also because I need a
place to sleep and I need to fill my
water and I need to throw out trash and
do all those chores so I think that's in
a way
I'm motivated to come to the parks more
than perhaps I would be in a house but
I don't know I guess only time will tell
um but I just love that I get to in a
way call these places home like
pretty
pretty amazing not gonna lie
most of you probably had a solid Wi-Fi
connection and a hot shower and you
probably got so much work done whereas I
have gotten nothing done and emails are
coming in being like
hey just following up and I'm like
[Music]
foreign